- All right so how did
you get started, Marie?
Like with tidying up, this whole thing.
(speaks Japanese)
- So I actually,
became very interested
in the art of tidying
at the age five.
(speaks Japanese)
And I was just very interested
in organizing things.
So I would organize my
family's items secretly,
and I would get in trouble for that.
(audience laughs)
- What?
You got in trouble?
I would pay my children to tidy up.
My five year old never does that.
(speaks Japanese)
- So after a lot of (mumbles),
but of course that was kind
of part of the process.
And at the age of 19 that's when I decided
to turn this organizational
tidying thing into my business.
- A beast, yeah.
Everyone's in.
So how does being tidy help
in other areas of your life?
(speaks Japanese)
- So I feel like when
you tidy something up,
you're not just tidying up your house,
it really kind of tidies up
your mind and your heart as well
(speaks Japanese)
- That's my issue.
- So through the tidying up process,
it kind of teaches yourself
what sparks joy in you,
and then once you kind
of train this muscle,
you can apply that to other
areas of your life as well.
- I'm in.
I need it.
(laughs)
So what's your process
of getting rid of things?
(speaks Japanese)
- The most important thing
is to organize and tidy
by category,
and the first step in doing so
is you have to take all the
items from that category
and collect them in a single space.
- [Kelly] Oh gosh.
(Marie speaks Japanese)
- So if you're gonna start with clothes,
then get every single article
of clothing in your house
in one space and you grab it,
you touch it, you feel it,
and you see if it sparks
joy inside of you.
- [Kelly] Is there anything you've had
a hard time letting go of?
(Marie speaks Japanese)
- So there's actually a t-shirt
that I purchased in 2005,
a long time ago that I
just can't get rid of.
- [Audience] Awww.
(laughs)
- [Kelly] It's so clean.
From 2005?
No stains?
What?
(speaks Japanese)
- Someone owns a Tide pen.
(laughs)
(Marie speaks Japanese)
- It's a little embarrassing,
and I can't explain why,
but it just sparks so
much joy inside of me.
And this is the first time
that I'm showing it on TV.
(audience laughs)
- You know what would spark joy in me,
if I could fit in it.
(audience laughs)
Anything that you're
still holding onto, Seth?
- I have a shirt I bought in college
that is a Bacardi rum shirt
that I found in a thrift store.
(audience laughs)
And there it is.
And it says,
"I'm rich, smooth, and flavorful."
And I've had it for 20+ years,
and I'm happy every time I see it.
(audience laughs)
- I was gonna say, "I don't
know, that sparks joy for me,
and it's not even mine."
(audience laughs)
Especially seeing your kid
hold up a Bacardi shirt.
(audience laughs)
- Also let's note the absence
of joy in my son's face.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
It's like, "Fine, dad."
- [Seth] It's sparking nothing.
- So Marie,
you just released your first kids book.
What is "Kiki & Jax" about?
(speaks Japanese)
- So I actually created this book
because I wanted to kind of
convey the joy of tidying up
to the younger generation.
(speaks Japanese)
And it's not just an instructional book
that teaches kids,
"This is how you tidy."
It's actually a story, a narrative about
how the two's friendship is kind of
based on this idea of tidying.
- Okay. I'm gonna take that home.
(audience laughs)
To read to my children.
All of them.
Even the teenagers.
(laughs)
Marie's new children's book,
"Kiki & Jax" is out now.
- [Beth] I'm obsessed with Marie Kondo
and the spark joy
decluttering extravaganza
that has taken over America.
- And in case you don't know her...
You pick things, right?
In your house?
- [Beth] Yes.
And you make sure that
they spark joy to you.
She has a whole thing, look,
I've read the book,
I've highlighted,
I've done every room in
my house but the garage,
and it's now this amazing sanctuary.
- [Kelly] So you feel better?
- I feel clearer.
I have more time.
It's amazing.
I'm like full-blown Marie Kondo,
like, bow down.
(laughs)
(audience laughs)
- All right, y'all.
(audience cheers and applause)
Please welcome Beth Behrs.
(soulful instrumental music)
(audience cheers and applause)
- Hi!
Oh my god!
Hi!
- [Kelly] Meet Seth.
- [Beth] I can't believe I'm here.
- [Beth] Hi Seth!
- [Seth] Hi Beth!
How are you?
It's good to see you.
- [Beth] Hi Kelly!
- [Kelly] Hi!
- [Kelly] I was so excited
you could come back!
(Beth claps)
- I have met so many actresses
and celebrities I love,
but you're my favorite ever.
(audience cheers)
- [Marie] Thank you.
- [Beth] I love you so much!
- Okay.
Marie, this is Beth,
and I swear she won't harm you.
- [Beth] I swear.
I mean, we'll see.
(laughs)
I don't know.
- [Kelly] Just kidding.
(laughs)
Is there anything that you
would want to say to Marie?
That's why we had you here.
We were like, "You gotta have a question."
- [Beth] Yes.
No, just thank you so much.
You say in your book,
and it's so true,
that it goes beyond decluttering.
Like, it really changes your whole life,
and I've had so much, like...
people walk into my house and be like,
"There's just a different energy in here.
Like, it just feels better."
- [Marie] Oh.
And I feel better,
and everybody should do it.
(laughs)
(audience cheers and applause)
- [Marie] Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I'm so happy.
(laughs)
- [Kelly] Beth used the KonMari
Method on her whole house.
We have some photos, let's see 'em.
- [Audience] Whoa!
- [Kelly] Look at those piles.
- [Marie] Wow!
(laughs)
- [Beth] Obviously that was the closet.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, this many.
- [Kelly] That's her
dog amongst the things.
- [Audience] Whoa!
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
It's getting better, getting better.
I fold, I roll like that.
- [Beth] So I have a tiny closet,
but that's the most room
I've ever had in it,
and I'm very proud of that.
(laughs)
- [Kelly] Dude, that was a
lot of clothes on the floor.
- [Beth] There was a lot.
- [Kelly] So how did Beth do?
(speaks Japanese)
- [Marie] Excellent.
(laughs)
- [Beth] Yay!
- [Kelly] All right.
Well, Beth do you have any
more questions for Marie?
Like, you said you have a tiny closet.
Is there anything?
- [Beth] Yeah.
So I have a tiny closet,
and I got rid of anything
that didn't spark joy,
but then I got some new
clothes that did spark joy.
(laughs)
And so,
now my closet doesn't
look like that anymore.
(laughs)
And I don't know why.
I miss that it...
It looked so good,
and now it looks more cluttered and,
can you help me?
(laughs)
(speaks Japanese)
- [Translator] So just understanding
the folding process very thoroughly,
that really kind of saves a lot
of space inside your closet.
- [Beth] Oh. Okay.
I didn't even think about that.
Like, folding it, yeah,
and shelves like that.
- [Kelly] Wait, well
aren't we about to learn
how to fold it properly?
Right?
(translates to Japanese)
I think so.
- [Beth] Yeah.
- [Kelly] You get the
"Kelly Clarkson Show" shirt.
- [Beth] This is good
too because I have a lot-
- [Kelly] You love Kelly-
- [Beth] I love Kelly Clarkson.
I have a lot of problems
with the (mumbles).
I always do it upside down
where you can't see the t-shirt.
I forget how to do it the
way you're supposed to.
- [Kelly] I worked a bit in apparel,
so you can usually see my...
I had a lot of jobs.
(laughs)
(speaks Japanese)
- Yeah so if you want to show the logo,
just make sure when you
start it's on the outside,
it's facing you.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Beth] Oh, facing.
- [Kelly] Oh.
So wait,
this is wrong?
This is wrong?
You shouldn't do this?
(speaks Japanese)
- [Translator] Oh, so you flip it over.
- [Beth] Oh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] Gosh, Seth.
You're so wrong.
- I'm doing good.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] I love that you have
a shirt for like a mini Seth.
(laughs)
- So how do you do it?
You fold this in?
(speaks Japanese)
- [Beth] Oh my god,
we're folding with Marie Kondo.
- [Kelly] I know.
(audience cheers)
I'm in, I'm in.
Okay, this is like the
proper way to get in there.
- [Translator] And of course,
make sure you pour in
some love as you do this.
- [Beth] Oh, yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay.
(translates to Japanese)
Wait, you do what?
You say you love it while you do it?
- [Beth] Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] That's not weird.
- [Translator] Make sure
you do it with love.
(Marie speaks Japanese)
- [Beth] I did something wrong.
- [Kelly] I love you.
- [Beth] Oh, you're right.
I've been doing it wrong.
(Marie speaks Japanese)
- [Translator] It's good
to make it a little skinny.
- [Kelly] - [Beth] Okay.
- [Kelly] Well.
- [Beth] Your mom's like, "Well."
(laughs)
(speaks Japanese)
- And then take the top,
pull it towards you.
- [Kelly] You are hysterical.
(laughs)
- Just want to say I'm already
done and mine's real small.
- [Kelly] Okay, yours is great.
Look at how perfect that is.
(speaks Japanese)
- [Kelly] Okay.
Oh, look, your smiley face is there.
I like it.
That's your spark of joy.
- [Beth] But did I do it wrong?
So what's next for you, Marie?
I heard you're expanding
your e-commerce shop, right?
(speaks Japanese)
- [Translator] Yeah so I
actually made an e-commerce shop
that is full of only things
that spark joy for me.
- [Beth] Ooh!
- [Kelly] Don't add it to your closet.
- [Beth] Oh, right. This is bad. (laughs)
- [Kelly] Well thank you so much.
Oh, your's is standing
perfectly straight up.
(audience applause)